we're driving through the Yungas a
stretch of rainforest valleys and rivers
along the eastern slopes of the Andes
for centuries this has been Bolivia's
main coca growing region growing and
selling coca is legal here
I've come to South America to one of the
largest coca growing countries in the
world people here - coca use it as
medicine and grew it into tea most of
them are coca farmers they get more
money for growing coca than they would
for other products like coffee beans I
meet here she's been picking coca leaves
for practically all of her life stuff in
sales Elysee that's a part se see the
coke has used to make cocaine how does
that make you feel well porque ellos
estaban Lord de la la coca sister so had
a coke a low behind el valor al decir
que el al Panello coup de coca neruda's
are Odessa forma en Sinestro a acuerdo
con esto toma esto en contra decada
porque si si - Nicholas a para curar
para para beneficio a no para no Daniel
a las personas
Hilda is 19 years old she lives in a
small farmhouse with her family for
generations under one roof Hilda is
especially close to her two younger
sisters four years ago his mother left
the family without warning or
explanation difficult add guests will be
on this actio que cuando master faith
it's fun and difficult at terminus
legacy is Colossians today mama
pero también superb un desafío and the
Sevilla porque eye IQ buscar no to love
better food to eat are they so been
Deborah stone sober para nada que in
Hilda's village I take a look at some of
the harvest once they've picked the coca
leaves the farmers lay them out to dry
the UN estimates that around 35,000
tonnes of coca leaves are sold illegally
for cocaine production each year that's
nearly two thirds of Bolivia's annual
production here that wants to get out of
the coca business every Tuesday she
travels 50 kilometres by foot and by bus
just to get to her University
mas que todo Donovan aqui por ser ET en
un trabajo seguro algo siesta play came
in super Azaria to Lucas connoisseur
nervous form as de de trabajo and si el
canto is a s consider it sacrificio you
know severe mamas includes totally desi
ambiente they it's a costumer that they
call to our coke
poor kid Mikado yo burner company
capacity you and you're sucking in the
youngest there's only one place to go
for higher education the UIC Carmen
pampa the school offers degrees in
practical fields like veterinary
medicine agricultural science and
nursing 700 students are enrolled here
it's a chance for a better life
Hilda is doing a degree in education she
takes me to the dorms where she shares a
room with eight other girls
my boy with the limited income from
going coca Hilda's family can hardly
afford her tuition trabajo seguro no
economical maintain Novus dismantle name
has seen only beer comedy co-host que
trabaja Mo's legalmente la coka nostra
tenancy pobres para los que a probation
negativa Mantella layla de la coka los
que hace market raha cocaina de noche la
mañana yeah getting courses out Casas a
partisan community near the school has
done a lot to bring the local population
out of poverty
with an education they are less likely
to end up working for the drug cartels
with her friends around
Hilda seems more confident and relaxed
many of them also come from coca
plantations and are studying here in
hopes to make some other plantations to
work some of the other women they say it
gives them energy and what is this for
hey papa sir Musa Becky Darcy
at first the plantation owner doesn't
want to talk to me he's afraid I'll say
in my reports that he's involved in the
cocaine business
stammers mmm how authorities had to
panic when a person making money they
knew he had made yet no no -
statistically case there are money and
autos and I know a lot - areas when I
asked her what she would say to a dealer
getting rich of her work he easily that
assumed porque lo que Google King koroki
consistent trabajo es bueno sera trabajo
asado dig no algo consciente is dinero
en el kebir name being a important scale
think as long as Cesario por que hacer
su dinero de algo negative us into kosis
maila's el dinero
Nasir empanada if they were turned into
cocaine the leaves her depicts in one
day could fetch 12,000 euros on the
European black market further herself
earns only around 13 euros a day money
she uses to help finance her dream of
becoming a teacher and leaving the
plantation for good